[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez les mains chaudes
vous aimez mes mains
elles sont
chaudes c'est important les mains la
peau c'est très
important vous aviez disparu je soignais
mon mari vous l'avez bien soigné
[Musique]
estt j'aimerais vous
aider
vous avez une jolie
bouche vous aimez ma bouche
elle est
jolie elle est jolie parce qu'elle est
grosse j'aime les grosses bouches mon
mari avait la bouche MCE vous êtes
[Rires]
courageuse c'est votre première sortie à
va dire d'habitude
enfin depuis l'événement que vous savez
je vais plutôt à bagatal ou dans les
squir sur les bords de loise avec mon
enfant vous n'avez qu'un enfant
ouais mais je souhaite en avoir
[Rires]
d'autres j'ai
chaud on pas chaud oui j'ai chaud
j'aimeir chaud je suis ch je me
disputais souvent avec mon mari à ce
sujet il avait la MAN d'ouvrir toutes
les fenêtres vous aviez un grand
appartement immense touteses fenêtres
ouvertes il prétendait que c'était plus
sain il était obsédé par la maladie de
quoi estil mort
[Musique]
congestion j'adorerai danser avec vous
j'adore danser oui ce ser
agréable sur ce rythme là surtout parce
qu'on peut
danser tranquillement oui ce serait très
agréable mon mari détestait la danse il
détesta ça je parvenais quelque fois à
l'entraîner dans des endroits comme
celui-ci seulement pour boire du whisky
qu il était ivre je pouvais commencer à
[Musique]
danser vous êtes né sous quel
signe Scorpion et
vous
g
inér vous croyez à l'astrologie je
suionné de ça je trve que c'est une sé
divine les gorpion terriblement termine
souvent très
[Musique]
mal j'ai déjà eu une aventure avec un
scorpion et alors un
désastre nous allons nous détruire c'est
probable je sens que vous allez être ATR
avec moi je vous le
promets j'ai peur je sais je voudrais
vous
échapper
essayez nous allons nous amuser tous les
deux nous n'allons pas nous
ennuyer je suis
ennuyer avec ce
mort ce qui me plaît en vous c'est que
vous êtes vivant
merveilleusement
[Musique]
vivant